I'll never forget this place it was very  profound what happened to me here I  could buy this place today and bulldoze  it if I wanted I remember my very first  job it was at a place called Magoo ice  cream parlor in Ottawa Canada and it was  incredibly traumatic for me and it  taught me a lesson that I've never  forgotten it ruled my life in business  from that day on this is Magoo's ice  cream parlor this was Magoo's ice cream  parlor it was my second day working  there and the owner had hired me to  scoop I scream it was right here the  counter was right here and  I was finishing work one day and she  said to me get down on your knees and  scrape the gum off the floor and she  looked at me like a witch  and I said no and she said you're fired  get out of my ice cream store right here  happy right I didn't even know what  fired meant  but within minutes I was on my bicycle  on my way home in utter shame in shock  that she had that kind of control over  my life